do you know the uh the the marriage
problem it's uh optimal stopping yes so
where it's an optimal dating strategy
where you
uh do you remember yeah i think it's
like something like you you you know
you've got like a set of 100 people
you're going to look through and after
how many
do you
now after that after going on this many
dates out of 100 at what point do you
then go okay the next best person i see
is that the right one and i think it's
like something like 37 percent
uh
it's one over e whatever that is right
which i think is
yeah
we're gonna fact-check that
um
yeah so but it's funny under those
strict constraints then yes after that
many people as long as you have a fixed
size pool
then you just pick the the per the next
person that is better than anyone you've
seen before yeah
um
have you tried this have you
incorporated it i'm one of those people
i might we're and we're going to discuss
this i
and
what do you mean those people
i try not to optimize stuff i try to uh
listen to the heart
i don't
think
um i
like my mind immediately is attracted to
optimizing everything
and i think that
if if you really give in to that kind of
addiction that you lose the
the joy of the small things the minutia
of life i think i don't know it says i'm
concerned about the addictive nature of
my personality in that regard
in some ways
while i think the on average people
under try and quantify things or try
under optimize
um there are some people who you know
it's like with all these things it's a
you know it's a balancing act i've been
on dating apps but i've never used them
i i'm sure they have data on this
because they probably have the optimal
stop and control problem because aren't
a lot of people that use social like
dating apps are on there for a long time
so the the the interesting
the interesting aspect is like all right
how long before you stop looking before
it actually starts affecting your mind
negatively such that you see
dating as a kind of um
a game
a kind of game versus an actual
uh
process of finding somebody that's going
to make you happy for the rest of your
life that's really interesting uh they
have the data i wish they would be able
to release that data and i do want to
it's okay cupid right i think they ran a
huge huge study on all of their yeah
they're more data driven i think yeah
i think there's a lot of opportunity for
dating apps in general you know even
bigger than dating apps people
connecting on the internet i just hope
they're more data driven
and it doesn't seem that way
i think like uh i've always
always thought that
good reads should be a dating app like
uh i've never used it the goodreads is a
good reason it's just list
like books that you've read okay and uh
allows you to comment on the books you
read and what the books you're currently
reading but it's a giant social networks
of people reading books and that seems
to be a much better database of like
interests of course to constrain you to
the books you're reading but like
that really reveals so much more about
the person allows you to discover shared
interests because books are kind of
window into the way you see the world
also like the kind of places
people you're curious about the kind of
ideas you're curious about are you a
romantic or are you cold calculating
rationalists are you uh are you into
iron rand or are you into bernie sanders
are you into whatever right and i feel
like that reveals so much more than like
a a person
trying to look uh hot from a certain
angle and a tinder profile well it would
also be a really great filter
in the first place for people it selects
for people who read books and are
willing to go and rate them and
give feedback on them and so on so
that's already a really strong filter
probably the type of people you'd be
looking for
you